[تصفيق]
نس
الله اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم اكثر من 800 من مسؤولي
الخدمه المدنيه في الولايات المتحده
واوروبا يوقعون بيانا يحذرون فيه من
سياسات حكوماتهم المتعلقه بحرب اسرائيل
على قطاع غزه واكدوا ان حكوماتهم تخاطر
بالتواطئ في واحده من اسوا الكوارث
الانسانيه في هذا القرن بحسب وصفهم محذرين
من ان هناك خطرا من مساهمه حكوماتهم في
الانتهاكات الجسيمه للقانون الانساني
الدولي وجرائم الحرب والاباده الجماعيه
وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط
بالتعليق الاول السلطات التركيه تعلن
القبض على سبعه اشخاص للاشتباه ببيعهم
معلومات لجهاز الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي
المساد وذلك في ولايتي اسطنبول وازمير حيث
رصدت التحقيقات قيام المساد بانشطه كجمع
معلومات عن السير الذاتيه لاشخاص
والمراقبه ووضع اجهزه تتبع ضد اهدافه من
خلال محققين خاصين مرتبطين
به بعد حكم قضائي بالسجن ثلاث سنوات حركه
النهضه ترفض الحكم الصادر في حق رئيسها
راشد الغنوشي والوزير السابق رفيق عبد
السلام وتعتبره مظلمه جديده تضاف الى سيل
المظالم التي تتعرض لها الحركه وسائر
القوى الديمقراطيه في تونس بحسب
تعبيرها وسط استمرارهم في التظاهر
والاحتجاج مزارعون فرنسيون يرفعون عددا من
الحواجز التي اغلقوا بها مداخل العاصمه
باريس بعد تنازلات قدمتها الحكومه
الفرنسيه اثر احتجاجات المزارعين ضد زياده
الضريبه على الوقود الزراعي وانخفاض
اجورهم والضرائب المرتفعه والقيود
التنظيميه المبالغ فيها الى
اللقاء